ARVIND JAIN: All right.
Welcome everyone.
My name is Arvind Jain, and I
have Satish Kamabala here with
me, with a first look at Google
on making the web fast.
And we're very excited to be
here today to talk about how
to measure the speed of your
websites in the real world.
So, before we start, why should
we measure the speed of
our websites in the
first place?
The answer, to me, is obvious.
I don't like to visit
slow websites.
I like to shop from responsive
and fast websites.
I like to read news, rather
than waiting for the news
piece to appear.
And I'm sure you're
all like me.
Nobody likes loading
slow web pages.
At Google, we actually
went a bit further.
We ran an experiment to
understand the relationship
between speed of our service
and its usage.
So in this experiment what we
did was we inserted an extra
delay in serving our search
results to our users.
And then waited to see, does
it actually impact usage?
Are the users using our
service more, or less?
And the answer was actually
very clear.
We saw a significant drop in
the usage of Google search,
even after adding a delay as
little as a few hundred
milliseconds.
And I think that applies to all
the websites out there.
A slow website results in lower
usage, less revenue, and
obviously poor user
experience.
So we all need to make sure that
all websites are fast and
responsive to our users.
Of course, you can't make things
faster if you don't
know how to measure it.
So tat's the topic of
our talk today.
How do you measure
the speed of a
website in the real world?
So we will talk about
three things today.
We'll start with talking about
HTML web timing standard,
which makes speed measurement
a web standard.
After that we'll talk about how
Google Analytics uses the
HTML5 web timing standard and
its Site Speed feature to make
real world speed data available
to its publishers.
And finally, based on that data
that we collect in Google
Analytics, we want to share some
statistics on how fast
the internet today is.
All right.
So HTML5 web timing API.
This is a new standard which
we're working on in the W3C.
Google and a bunch of other
companies are involved in
standardizing this
as we speak.
Until very recently, it was not
possible for us to measure
the end-to-end user-perceived
time it takes
to load a web page.
It was just not possible,
because a lot of time is
actually taken in doing things
like establishing a DNS
connection to your website,
connecting to the website,
sending a request for the
web page, and then
start getting a response.
And the JavaScript actually
has no clue of all of this
time, where this
is being spent.
So this standard actually allows
us to collect that
end-to-end time that it takes
to load a web page.
And you can do this from any
browser, irrespective of what
device you're on.
Whether you're on a mobile
phone, or whether you're on a
laptop, or a notebook,
it doesn't matter.
All browsers that support this
standard will allow you to
collect speed data in
a consistent manner.
The specification consists of
three different standards.
Navigation timing, resource
timing, and user timing.
Before I go into the details
of this, first let's take a
look at what happens when you
load a web page in a browser.
So in this waterfall
view we're loading
the YouTube's homepage.
And this figure shows all the
different things that happen
when you load that web page.
The very first thing that the
browser does is connect to
your web server and download
the root web page.
In this case, the YouTube
homepage.
Index.html5.
Once that root page comes
back, the browser
starts to parse it.
It executes any scripts that it
finds on the page, and it
discovers new resources that
are acquired by this page.
And it will start downloading
them as well.
And this process continues until
all the scripts on the
page have been executed and
all the individual HTTP
objects have been downloaded,
for example images or CSS
files or scripts.
And once all of that is done,
that is when the page is
considered fully loaded.
In this chart, it's right
at the end of the chart.
The navigation timing API,
that's the first standard that
allows you to capture this
end-to-end time, starting from
when user navigates to
the page to when the
page is fully loaded.
In addition, it also gives
you very detailed timing
statistics for the
root web page.
For example, how long did it
take to do the DNS resolution
for youtube.com in
this example?
How long does it take to
establish the TCP connection
to the web host?
And so on and so forth.
Here is a list of all the
different timing attributes
that are available to you, via
a simple JavaScript API.
The list of attributes contains
network level
attributes.
For example, how long does it
take to the DNS resolution, or
how long does it take
to do the TCP
connection to your web server?
It also includes HTTP level
attributes, like how long does
it take to download
the response,
the actual web response?
And finally it also contains
document level attributes,
like how long does it take to
fully render the web page?
All of these attributes are
available via a single
JavaScript object, called
window.performance.timing.
Satish will show us a demo of
navigation timing in action.
SATISH KAMBALA: Hi all.
Here I have my Chrome
browser open.
Like any normal user, I'm
going to a website.
Let's visit news.com.
I'm waiting for the
page to be loaded.
Still loading.
Now the page load
has completed.
In this browser, I'm going to
the wrench icon and opening
JavScript console, by
going to the Tools
and JavaScript Console.
So here let's see whether
[? event load ?] is
available or not.
Window.performance.timing.
So you can see this object and
all the attributes that were
shown in the diagram.
So just look at some timings
from this object.
Storing [INAUDIBLE]
variable.
So loadEventEnd tells, after the
load has finished, since
the navigation start.
And I can see that this page has
taken four seconds, like
4.3 seconds approximately.
That's the end of the timing.
Response and minus
response start.
So this represents the time for
downloading the HTML from
the root page, which
is very fast.
So the main HTML is fast.
But if you can see the screen
capture, the overall page has
taken a lot of time
to load this.
So this data is available for
any website, in all the
browsers that support navigation
timing API.
So [INAUDIBLE] for the demo.
ARVIND JAIN: Thank you Satish.
So as you can see, navigation
timing allows you to capture
the end-to-end page load time
for your web page, as well as
detailed timing stats for
the root page only.
And it's not that interesting
when you saw in the previous
example, it took less than 100
milliseconds to load the main
root page, which is because we
serve YouTube from a location
close to you always.
So it doesn't take that
much time to actually
serve the root page.
Most of the time is actually
spent in downloading all of
the resources.
And this is true for most of
web pages out there today.
On average, I think web pages
have about 50 or so
resources per page.
It's not atypical to have even
more than 100 resources for
most of the popular web pages.
And most of the time is actually
spent downloading
those resources.
And that's where our second
specifications come into play.
This is the resource timing
specification.
This allows you to collect
timing information for every
individual resource
on the page.
And just like navigation timing,
you have a variety of
different attributes available
for every individual resource
on the page.
These include network level
timing stats, like time to DNS
resolve for the particular
resource and the time it took
to do the PCP connect for the
resource, as well as HTTP
level attributes like
the time to
download the actual resource.
This data is available for every
single resource that's
on the page.
It could be an image or a script
or object, iframe, svg.
All the different
object types.
And just like navigation timing,
this information is
available through the
JavaScript API.
And we'll take a look at an
example to see how that works.
So in this particular example
what we're going to do is, for
this given web page, we want
to see how long it takes to
download every image
on the page.
So the first thing that we do is
we call this method called
getEntriesByType on the
window.performance object.
This gives us a list of all the
individual resources that
are on the page.
Well, actually, it gives you
a list of all the resource
timing objects that the page
has saved for you.
And next we're going through
that list and checking for the
resources which are of the
type image, using the
initiator type field.
And all we do in this case is
just alert the time it took to
actually download that resource,
which is the
difference between
the response and
the start time attribute.
So with navigation timing and
resource timing, you can
capture detailed timing
statistics for the overall web
page and for all the individual
resources on the page.
But as you all know, that
web is changing.
And [INAUDIBLE], we can't really
think of just resources
when we want to actually
capture timing.
Many web pages are
now applications.
And developers need the ability
to measure the time it
takes to do logical operations
on their web pages.
And many times those logical
operations do not necessarily
correspond to HTTP
level resources.
And that's where the user
timings API comes into play.
User timing allows you to
capture the time it takes you
to do a specific logical
operation on the page.
It's provides a buffering
mechanism for you to capture
any arbitrary start point and
end point in the application.
And on top of that, it also
provides you with a high
precision timer, which is useful
when you do detail and
fine grain timing
measurements.
So collectively, these three
APIs, navigation timing,
resource timing, and user
timing, they allow you to do
detailed timing instrumentation
for your web
pages, and collect this data
from the real world.
These standards are not
all implemented
yet, by all the browsers.
Navigation timing is available
in most modern browsers now,
and resource timing and user
timing implementations are
also expected soon.
So with this we want
to switch gears.
And now Satish is going to talk
about how we use the web
timing API in Google Analytics
to provide real world speed
data to our publishers.
SATISH KAMBALA: Thanks Arvind.
So it's great to have all this
data right inside the browser.
But think about every website
owner changing the website to
read the data from the browser,
sending it back to
the servers, processing it,
and seeing the reports.
Basically, to get a view of the
real world web performance
is a very tedious process.
So that's where we offer
a service called Google
Analytics Site Speed that does
this automatically for you,
and provides this data without
doing any work.
So how many of you have used
Google Analytics before?
OK.
I think most of you know it.
So as you know it's a service
that lets you measure the user
engagement on your website.
Typically to set up Google
Analytics on your website, you
get an ID for you, and write
some script to download the
Analytics script asynchronously,
and add a
couple of lines.
They look like this.
You provide your Analytics ID to
the account, and also call
trackPageview, which actually
starts collecting user
engagement information
on your website.
To get the Site Speed set up,
you don't need to do anything.
Analytics, by default, collects
speed data for your
site at one person sampling.
So if you have a large website,
you can actually get
a substantial [INAUDIBLE]
for your site load time with
this sampling percentage.
But it your site is small, like
if you have 100 or 1,000
pages per day, we provide an API
to improve the sample rate
for the speed collection.
So this API is
setSiteSpeedSampleRate.
So you should call that API
before calling trackPageview.
So it collects most
speed data.
One thing I want to mention here
about the sampling is we
do the sampling on a visit
by visit basis.
So if a user comes to your
website, and if he falls in
the sample, we track speed
data for all the
pages in that session.
So that when you go back to
the reports later, you can
analyze the user behavior on
a session by session basis.
So we don't sample per page,
we sample on a session by
session level.
So before seeing how you can
see all this data, let's go
back to the diagram that
we saw earlier
for navigation timing.
So the top bar here, it shows
the page view process that you
saw earlier.
The bottom bar maps those
attributes to the timings that
you can actually represent.
So the first thing is the
redirection time.
So if your page has some
redirections before the final
landing page is finished,
that is captured in
the redirection time.
Mostly, if you're getting a
difference from the search
engines of other websites, you
can see how fast they're
sending them to your site
by looking at this time.
DNS and connection times,
they collect the network
attributes, as shown in
the navigation timing.
And the other one, server
response time, this is an
important metric.
So this measures the time from
the moment the browser sends a
request to your backend
since the first byte
arrives to the browser.
So it represents the time your
backend takes to respond to
the user request.
It also includes the time to the
first byte to the browser.
So if you want to understand
your backend performance from
the real world users, you can
actually look at this time.
And page download time
is the time to
download the entire content.
So starting from the first
byte to the last byte.
So this varies based on your
site content and user
connection speed.
Frontend time is the time,
after your root page is
downloaded, the time the browser
takes to pass the
HTML, execute the JavaScript,
download any additional
resources that are there, like
you were seeing earlier, and
basically render the whole page
and show to the user,
until the page loads.
I've basically scaled this
diagram to show the
significance of these timings,
in general what we saw from
the data we have.
But depending upon your site and
based on the user, these
scalings can vary.
Let's look at how you can see
all these reports, using a
demo in Analytics.
So I have Google
Analytics open.
The URL is
google.com/analytics/web.
At the top you can see
several reports.
So Site Speed reports are
available in the standard
reporting section.
Then you go to the content,
and you can see Site Speed
here, which has all
these reports.
So it has three reports.
Overview, page timings,
and user timings.
Let's look at overview
report now.
So I am hiding this so that
you can see the full view.
So Analytics by default shows
data for the past one month.
So overview report gives a quick
summary of your website
performance for the
past one month.
So it shows you all the timings
that I explained
earlier, starting with average
page load time and all the
other metrics that we saw.
You can actually change
this graph to show any
metric that you want.
And overview also gives you
shortcuts to see the speed
data on common dimensions
like browser,
country, and per page.
Coming to the page, your website
might have many pages,
and overall site speed load time
might not give you enough
insight to improve
your website.
So that's where page timings
report comes in.
It lets you look at your speed
data on a page by page basis.
So the page timings report shows
a graph similar to the
above, and it also shows
you a table.
And this table gives you a list
of page load times for
the top 10 pages.
So we show the average page
load time on pageviews.
We just sorted by
the pageviews.
So we can actually see the top
10 pages for your website and
see how they're performing
in terms of loading.
In addition to the page load
time, we also show some
important metrics, like bounce
rate and percent of exit.
So these metrics actually
vary from page to page.
So if your page is taking a
long time, people usually
abandon before the page loads,
and they actually go to the
other site.
So these metrics are important
on a page by page basis.
We show them alongside the page
load time, so you can get
a view of how this is affecting
the other metrics.
So in this analytics
reporting, we
have three tabs here.
Explorer, Performance,
and Map Overlay.
So below the Explorer tab we
have another section called
Technical, which shows the
other metrics, basically.
Page load time is the first
metric to see overall.
And if you are caring about a
specific metric, like server
response time, you can actually
come to the technical
section and then see them.
This is similar to
the site usage.
It has a graph, and you can
change to any metric.
And it also gives the table of
pageviews and all the other
timing metrics.
So you might be wondering, in
all these reports I've shown
until now, I'm only showing
average page load time.
But latency distribution is not
normal distribution, so
average does not represent
your site
performance for all users.
So if you have some users who
are experiencing large page
load times, that can actually
skew your average and might
actually give you a wrong
picture of your website load.
So we do do some
filtering, like
removing extreme outliers.
Like more than 10 minutes load
time, if it is there we can
have it removed from
these calculations.
But if there are some users who
take one or two minutes,
that can actually skew
your average.
So that's where this
Performance
tab comes into picture.
So Performance tab shows you the
latency distribution for
your site, across different
speed buckets.
So in this diagram I can see
that m latency solution is
like zero to one second.
10% of the users are
experiencing less than one
second page load time,
which is pretty good.
And 40% of users are
experiencing
one to three seconds.
So I can actually see from this,
even though my average
page load time is 3.3 seconds,
around 80% of the users are
experiencing latency below
three seconds.
So I feel pretty confident,
OK, my site is doing OK.
But there are some users
who are experiencing
more than one minute.
So I might want to look at them
and then see whether I
can do something for them.
Finally the Map Overlay here
gives you the site performance
data on a region by
region basis.
And why is region important?
Because most of the time you
host your website in one
region, but you might get users
from different locations
in the world.
So you not only want to look at
the user experience based
on speed buckets, but you want
to see how users in other
regions are experiencing
your website.
So here, similar [INAUDIBLE]
reports.
We show the top 10 countries
that get the pages from you,
and show the page load time
for those countries.
And the map gives a quick
summary to say.
It has a lot of gradients.
So thick green color kind of
shows that the people in that
country are experiencing
high latency.
Light color shows
they are fast.
So we just went through an
overview of all these reports
and analytics.
But I wanted to give an example
of how my friend used
these reports to see his latency
has changed as he made
improvements to his website.
So he's a good blogger.
And also his [INAUDIBLE], so
he keeps making performance
improvements to his site.
And let's see how he has seen
the speed change over time.
So he had a New Year's
resolution
to improve his blog.
So around December end, he kind
of changed his blogging
provider, posting from one
platform to another platform.
So here I am comparing
generated data
compared to the December.
So the blue lines represent
January, the new provider, and
the orange lines represent
December.
So it shows that the average
page load time has increased
by 25% after this change.
So in January it shows that
there is a significant
improvement.
So we can see that the change
has really worked for him.
So there is an improvement in
the average page load time.
Not only that, there is an
improvement in page views.
Which could be coincidental
or as a result of speed.
But it's a good thing for him
to change the provider.
So this is just a change
in the average.
Let's see how the distribution
has changed.
So the orange bars, that
is before the change.
You can see that they're
scattered over one to three
second buckets, and three
to seven seconds.
So people are evenly
distributed.
Some people are even
experiencing
seven to thirteen seconds.
But after the change,
that color has
shifted to the left side.
Most of the users are now seeing
zero to one seconds,
one to three second buckets.
And some users are still
in the three to
seven bucket range.
So this gives me an idea, OK,
not that the average has
improved, but most of the users
also have shifted to the
speed of the buckets.
So one thing is his old hosting
provider used to
generate the web pages
dynamically.
So there's a database created
that is happening when
somebody goes to his website.
And the new provider actually
recalculates them and then
stores those images
statically.
So because this is related to
the backend time, let's see
how the server response
time has changed.
So if you look at the orange
bars, which is the old hosting
provider, he's generating
the pages dynamically.
His distribution is bimodal.
So there is a set of users in
the 0.1 to 0.5 seconds, and
there is another set
of users in the one
to two second bucket.
So this can be explained by
saying if the queries in the
backend are actually cached,
they are getting the pages
faster and they're falling
in this bucket, 0.1
to 0.5 second buckets.
Or if the query is not cached,
they're actually falling into
the second bucket.
After his shift, because
the pages are generated
statically, they are moved
to the faster buckets.
So that can be seen in
this distribution.
So these reports actually help
you understand how these
changes are happening as you
make site improvements.
One interesting thing, if you
see here in January the first
half of the month he's seen
varying page load times.
So he did some investigation,
and he found that in the Asian
region the [INAUDIBLE]
was erratic and it
was timing out.
That caused actually
this increase.
So he put another to do
to fix the social
widgets on his blog.
So he told me that he has
fixed it recently.
So let's see whether that
made a difference.
And seeing the data
from May to June,
average page load time.
There is an annotation
that he added.
So he tells me that on May 25th
he changed his site such
that he preferred the loading
of all social widgets on his
page to happen after that
page actually loads.
So as you can see, after this
the average page load time is
hovering from two the
three seconds.
Compared to eight to nine
seconds, which is a big
improvement.
So you can observe all these
improvements in these reports.
Let's get back to the slides.
So this is just a summary of
what we have seen so far.
You have an overview report,
page timings, there is a
technical section, the
histograms, map overlay.
So page timings and over report
gives you by default,
without doing any work, your
site page load latency.
But as you learned earlier, most
of the user interaction
happens after the page loads.
Because nowadays the websites
are complex and they're mostly
behaving like applications, you
want to measure the time
after the page actually loads.
That's where user
timing comes in.
It lets you define user defined
custom timings.
You can define any action of
what you want in your website,
and measure the timing
with this.
So if you have Ajax actions that
are happening, you can
measure those timings.
If you want to get detailed
performance measurements, like
on your page you want to measure
how much time each
widget is taking to load, or how
much time CSS is taking to
load, you can do that with the
detailed instrumentation.
Or if you have a site like a
news website, where they're
not concerned about the page
load time, but they're
concerned about how long it
takes to show the main article
to the user, they'd want user
perceived load time, and then
start reporting analytics.
So user timings allows you
to do all of that.
And the way to do it is using
an API called trackTiming.
So this API has five
parameters.
First three of them
are required,
other two are optional.
Let's go through one by one.
So first parameter
is category.
So what we have noticed is,
even instead of Google, we
also try to make all
the apps fast.
What we noticed is most of the
people start instrumenting,
and then keep adding a lot
of variables and they
pile up over time.
So we have made it mandatory to
say specify a category as a
first parameter, so you can
group your variables into
separate logical things.
So for example, if I take a
YouTube website, I can define
category as watch page,
homepage, search page,
settings page.
So at a high level, I can see
which page I am creating a
report for tracking
the latency.
The second parameter is a
variable, which is like the
JavaScript load time
or [INAUDIBLE]
action load time
kind of thing.
And this is a time.
And we provide one millisecond
resolution.
So you can specify the time to
track timing at a millisecond
resolution.
And you can see all of
that in the reports.
The other two optional
parameters are label and
sample rate.
So here a label is any arbitrary
text that you can
attach to your user
timing data.
So the way to use labels
is if you're doing some
experimentation--
like Google web search does
thousands of experiments every
day, and I want to see how one
experiment is performing
against others, or how my
experiment is changing the
speed data.
So you can attach your
experiment as a label, and see
the data for a particular
category and
variable along them.
So this is very powerful,
because you don't want to do
some speed change without
knowing how
much it actually improves.
So you can do an experiment and
attach some label and see
how it performs, and
then make it 100%.
The sample rate here is similar
to the Site Speed
sample rate.
So the reason we provide the
sample rate API is because if
you send too many hits to the
Google Analytics, when you
look at them in the reports
they'll take a
long time to load.
And they also do some sampling
while generating the reports.
So if your site is small, you
should definitely increase the
sample rate.
But if your site is large, like
more than one million or
10 million, you should keep it
in the default sample rate.
Let's see how this track
timing API can be
used with an example.
So this example tries to measure
the time to load a
[INAUDIBLE]
that is loaded through Ajax.
So I defined a class
called TimeTracker.
So I'm using this class as a
helper class that stores the
category, variable and other
bookkeeping for me.
[INAUDIBLE]
class.
And when I make xhr request,
before I send the request I
record the start time.
And after I get the response
and validate that it's a
success, I measure
the end time.
And then I kind of send the data
to Google Analytics by
calling this trackTiming.
So the main things are you just
record you start time,
record your end time, and
then just make a call to
trackTiming.
That it as simple as it is.
So it's very simple to do
these user timings using
trackTiming API, but this
is also very powerful.
You can use this trackTiming
API to measure any timing.
For example, you have a web
page, and you want to measure
how long the user takes
before he interacts
with your web page.
So you can measure the time
using this trackTiming API.
So at this point you may be
wondering, you have user
timing specification in the
browser, and we have user
timings in the Google
Analytics.
How do these two
work together?
These two actually compliment
each other.
Because if you notice in this
example, I am creating a class
called TimeTracker that
is doing a lot of
bookkeeping for me.
Storing the category, variable,
recording the start,
recording the end.
And if you noticed, user timings
API actually does the
same thing for you.
So it provides an API to measure
the start and end
measures, and [INAUDIBLE]
through them.
So the advantage of that is you
don't need to pass these
variables around.
I don't need to create an object
and pass it around my
JavaScript code, which kind of
makes the whole code look
uglier, less variable, because
I'm passing performance
related data throughout.
But if you have it in the
browser, at any point in your
code you can say start
measurement for a particular
name, variable name, and
[INAUDIBLE] measure, and then
report it using the
track timing.
So user timing API can be used
for buffering the data, and
track timing can be used to send
the data to Analytics.
So you can make them
work together.
So I'm not going to demo the
user timings report, because
it's very similar to
the page timings.
You have the same three tabs,
Explorer, Performance, and Map
Overlay tabs.
And if you see on the bottom,
we have a dimension to slice
and dice the data by.
So like I was saying, we provide
several ways to look
at user timings data.
We have a category at a high
level, we have a label as a
tagging mechanism.
So you can look at a particular
variable data and
compare how it is doing across
different categories.
Like how long my social widgets
are taking to load on
my home page, compared
to watch page.
Or you can see how a particular
variable is taking
across different levels.
You can plug them together and
see which one is better.
So you can do that powerful
slice and dice using these
dimensions.
And in the Performance tab, we
have a single set of buckets
that are provided for
all the timings.
These buckets are designed in
such a way that we can measure
granular timings, like
JavaScript things that usually
are in the range of 10
milliseconds, things that
happen on the client side.
Or you can also measure
large load times that
take a lot of minutes.
We provided buckets starting
with 0.1 seconds, until one
minute or more.
At the high level, we give
some buckets first.
But if you want to dig deeper we
provide sub-buckets, so you
can go expend those buckets
and then see
how those are varying.
So until now we have seen how
page timings and user timings
give you a complete tool set
for measuring your website
performance.
But that's not all that Google
Analytics can do for you.
It can do even more.
You can create custom reports.
By custom reports I mean you
can create a table of any
metric that you care about,
along any dimension that you
are really interested in.
For example here, let's take
a look at this table.
Visitor Caching Info.
I'm plotting my average
page load time based
on the visitor type.
Visitor type is a standard
dimension that is available in
the Analytics.
So I can see my returning
visitors are experiencing
faster pages compared
to new visitors.
This is obvious because some
of the resources on my page
might be cached, so they
see faster load times.
So this way you can actually
plot your latency versus some
revenue metrics, or some goals
that you're interested in.
You can create any custom
report that
you want using Analytics.
Not only that, you can actually
create dashboards.
This is a simple dashboard
which has all these four
tables that I created.
So these dashboards can be
accessed in the home
[INAUDIBLE].
So the standard reporting is
where we saw the reports.
So the dashboards can be
seen in this home page.
And then we provide an API to
expose all the data that you
have seen in the reports
through the API.
So if you don't like the
reports, you can actually pull
the data using the API and draw
your own visualizations.
You can plot whatever you want
in whatever way you want, on
your web page server,
on your websites.
You don't need to
come to Google
Analytics to see this data.
Another powerful feature
of Google
Analytics is advanced segments.
So what advance segments let
you do is see any reporting
Google Analytics for
a segment of users.
You can define any segment of
users the way you want.
You can create the
segments very
easily, in multiple steps.
Here I'm again using some
default segments that are
already created.
So there is a segment called
search traffic, which shows
the data for traffic coming
from the search results.
And I have a direct traffic
segment, which shows data
people who visit my
site directly.
And I am seeing the technical
section of all the metrics
across these two segments.
You can do this segmenting
across any reports.
User timing sites, page
timings, or any other
[INAUDIBLE]
metrics also.
And these reports are good.
You can see all the data.
But you won't be looking at the
reports 24 hours a day.
But you are speed-conscious,
and you want to be notified
when something changes,
something significantly
changes to your website
performance.
So that's why Analytics allows
you to set up alerts.
So you can set alerts to be
notified when something
happens to your site, and it
automatically sends you email,
or phone, or SMS,
or something.
Whatever you said.
Here there's an example.
I'm asking you to alert me when
my average page load time
increases by more than 10%
compared to the same day in
previous week.
Because your page view traffic
or page load time, all these
graphs vary based
on the week day.
Weekend, you might have more
traffic or less traffic,
depending on your content.
So for the same day of the
previous week, if my page load
time changes by more than
10% I want to be sent
an email or an SMS.
This is the result
of the email.
So it shows me that my average
page load time has
increased by 67%.
Not only does it give me an
alert, it also gives me some
reasons why this alert
could be happening.
This is, again, based
on the correlation.
So this may not be the actual
reason, but you can actually
take this as a starting
point and debug why
it could have happened.
So in this case, people from
India, New Delhi city, are
experiencing high load
times, which caused
my average to increase.
So if I have a background in
that region, I can go and see
if there is a problem
with me set up.
Or if there's a network already
in that region, I can
do such kind of analysis.
So far we have seen how Google
Analytics gives you several
ways to see your performance
of the website.
But if you have some apps--
native apps, like iOS apps
or Android apps--
there is a good talk that is
tomorrow, to see how Analytics
helps you measure the end-to-end
value of your apps.
You should attend that.
It's at 11:30 tomorrow
morning.
So measuring your speed is the
first step of improving your
website speed.
Because this talk is about
that measurement, I'm not
going to look into how you can
optimize the websites.
But I'll give you some pointers
to some tools that I
frequently use.
Web page test is nice tool to
see your website performance
in a lab scenario.
So you can simulate a user,
using a browser, coming from a
location, and see how
your page loads.
It gives you waterfall charts.
In fact, the waterfall charts
that we were showing earlier,
one of them was taken from
the web page test.
You can also see video
strip of the web
page loading process.
So it takes snapshots of your
web page at several points of
the load time.
So if it takes 10 second to
load, that'll be like 50
snapshots, from zero to ten
seconds, at several points.
And vendors actually use it to
see some content of the page
being loaded using
that video strip.
So this is a very good tool for
analyzing your web page
and how it behaves.
And the Chrome Developer Tools,
again I used it earlier
to show how
window.performance.timing
object shows the data.
This is also very powerful to
analyze your web pages.
There was a talk about
it Tuesday morning.
So If you missed it, the
talk was recorded.
So you can go and watch
it on YouTube later.
So Analysis is good
to understand how
your website is doing.
And optimization is
the next step.
We have a group called Page
Speed Insights, that analyses
your web page and gives you
suggestions to improve your
speed, based on the best
practices that we have known
and we have learned for years.
So you don't need
to do anything.
If you go to that link, enter
your website, it gives you
[INAUDIBLE] suggestions.
Based on the priority, again.
So you can go ahead and change
your website to implement
those solutions.
But there are tools which
actually do this suggestion
implementation automatically
for you.
So we have an Apache module
called mod_pagespeed.
So if you use that module, it
implements those page speed
suggestions automatically.
It rewrites your web page,
and then serves it.
So you get the benefit
without much work.
And we also a Page
Speed Service.
It's the service--
if you point your domain name
to the service, it does the
serving as well as the rewriting
part for you.
So you get the benefits of
Google infrastructure, where
your website will be served
from location close to the
user, as well as these best
practices applied to your
website content.
If you have a Google App Engine
app, we have made it
even easier for you.
There is a simple check box
where you can say enable page
speed service for my
Google Engine app.
And it will do what Page Speed
Service does for your Google
Engine app automatically.
And if you want to learn more
about the App Engine app,
there is a session tomorrow
morning at
11:30, in room [? 304, ?]
I guess.
You can learn more there.
So with this I will hand over
to Arvind, who has some
interesting data, and will tell
you how fast the web is
from our point of view.
ARVIND JAIN: Thank you Satish.
So Google Analytics is a really
good tool to measure
the speed of your website
in the real world.
And I think more importantly
than that, it actually allows
you to understand the
relationship between speed and
other business metrics
that you care about.
For example, how much revenue
you make, our how many page
views do you get for
your website.
So it's a great tool.
You should work on making your
site fast, and then you should
convince yourself.
You can see the data in Google
analytics, and see how it
actually improves your other
business metrics.
Google Analytics has lots
and lots of users.
We have millions of
websites that
actually use Google Analytics.
And from that we've been
collecting a lot of data on
the performance of
these websites.
If you look in aggregate, that's
a good enough data set
for us to proxy the performance
of the entire web.
So that's what we did.
We did a study on one
[INAUDIBLE] called site speed
data from Google Analytics.
This was done using data from
publishers who actually
allowed us to do these kinds
of studies, by opting into
aggregate analysis.
And these are the results
from that study.
So first of all, the
web is not fast.
I mean I think this is one of
the things that we all need to
work on, make sure that our
websites are really fast.
On desktop it takes well over
six seconds, on average, to
load a web page.
That's a lot of time.
Just imagine sitting for six
seconds, not doing anything,
just waiting for the
page to load.
On mobile, it's even worse.
It takes well over 10 seconds on
average to load a web page.
And by the way, this mobile
data is from Android ICS
builds only.
So these are really the best
phones that are out there.
And even those are quite slow.
The other chart shows the
different histograms.
But the story remains
the same.
The web is quite slow
as of today.
This is another interesting
navigation.
Here we show how fast
the web is for all
these different countries.
There's actually a heat map,
there's a link to a heat map
here where you can see the
performance of the internet in
any given country.
The data is sort of obvious.
It shows that the web is fast
in countries where you would
expect it to be.
I think it's sort of well-known
that countries like
Japan and Sweden, they have
really good broadband
connections to the home.
Often in excess of 100
megabits per second.
And that sort of shows
in this data.
But why is that important
to you?
One of things--
we at Google, we really
care about this data.
And we want to make sure that
our web services have the same
level of responsiveness, no
matter where the user is.
So if the user is coming from
a slow connection, or if a
user is coming from a really
fast connection, we want to
make sure that we provide them
with the same responsive
experience, even if that means
that we have to sacrifice on
some features.
So we would often go and cut
some features from our
products, so that we can still
maintain those low page load
times for our users.
As an example, for Google Maps
we can solve them with
low-resolution titles.
For Google search, we can
actually remove some of the
features which are not commonly
needed, or we can
defer loading them and make
them available later.
Gmail, again, has the same kind
of experience, where for
slow connections we would
actually show them a more
traditional, web 1.0 style
email interface.
Where you get to see your emails
really fast, but you
won't get all the cool
features, like
Hangouts and what not.
So that's sort of the design
philosophy that we follow.
And we often notice that that
is actually very useful, and
helps us keep those users in
those countries where the
connections are slow.
And that's something for
you to consider as
well, for your websites.
This is yet another
aggregation.
This shows the speed
of the web across
different industry verticals.
And sort of interesting--
entertainment sites, as an
example, tend to be fairly
rich, with a lot of images.
And that sort of materializes
into slow page load times.
And the same question emerges
again, why should you care
about this?
So one of the things that is
actually good to know, where
does your site stack up?
As compared to your competitors,
for example.
So you can go to Google
Analytics, look at how fast
your website is, and then
compare the performance of
your website with these
aggregates.
For example, you can find out
whether your site is typical,
or slower, or faster than other
websites in your region.
Or whether it's slower or
faster compared to other
websites in the business
as yours.
So this is all we have today.
This concludes our
presentation.
Thank you all for coming.
And we would love to take any
questions that you might have.
AUDIENCE: Question about
the custom metrics
that you can collect.
I saw in your example you were
measuring the beginning and
end of a particular operation.
Is there a way to just capture
how far you are from the very
beginning of when the web
page began to load?
Say that you're loading some
resources via Ajax shortly
after the page loads, so that
it's comparable to--
it's on the same timeline as
the rest of the performance
events, this long to
get to this step,
this step, this step.
SATISH KAMBALA: So the
navigation timing API has this
fetch start.
That's one of the attributes in
the navigation timing API,
that tells when the page
started to fetch.
So you can base all of
your end times with
[? respect to ?]
the fetch start, so we can
compare them one by one.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Cool, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Ads are often
a major issue with web
performance.
And they're also
very variable.
Is it possible to remove those
from those timings, so you can
check your pages outside of ads,
in case the ad stuff is
not something that you're
able to control.
ARVIND JAIN: Yes.
I think that's a difficult
thing to do.
Because when you load a web
page, your ads are actually
just one of the 100 resources,
for example,
that have been loaded.
And it's really hard to tell
what would happen if those ads
were not there.
You can certainly
look at the--
there are other tools.
For example you can use Web Page
Test, or you can use Dev
Tools, to actually see the
waterfall and see that your
ads are actually sort of coming
in the way of your
actual content from
getting loaded.
So that's one of the ways to
actually see whether ads make
things worse.
Now the other thing to do is you
can actually measure the
performance of your
ads by themselves.
For example you can use user
timings to extract the time
from the start of an ad quest
to when the ad request
actually comes back.
That sort of tells you
how long does the
ads actually take.
And if your ads are blocking,
like if they actually block
the content of web page, they'll
show the actual impact
of those ads on the web
page performance.
So you can actually look at the
data, and you can manually
definitely try to figure out
the actual impact of ads on
the web pages.
The right thing, in my opinion,
is to actually use
ads properly.
And many ad networks, definitely
all Google ad
products these days, the
recommended way to include
them is to load them
asynchronously, so that they
don't actually come in the way
of your web page performance.
Seems like that's it.
So thank you again.